[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
BILD am 7 januar
2015 hatte ich Dienst im Produktionsraum
von BILD am Vormittag ich war damals
Chef vom Dienst in der Videoabteilung
und am Vormittag irgendw ich erinnere
das zwischen 10 uh und 11 uh 11:30 Uhr
also Vormittagszeit vielleicht auch bis
12 Uhr da gab es Eilmeldung und ganz
erschütternde Bilder weil es mitten in
Paris einen Anschlag auf eine Redaktion
gab und zwar auf die Redaktion der
Satirezeitschrift Charlie APPD das war
also jetzt ich ich sitze da ich habe
erste Videoschnipsel verarbeitet
abgesprochen was man wie in welcher
Reihenfolge zeigen kann und diesen
Arbeitstag den werde ich nie
vergessen
in den nächsten zwei Episoden behandeln
wir Geschehnisse die durch den
grauenhaften Terror in Israel wieder
sehr lebendig erscheinen wir erinnern an
die Anschläge in Paris im Jahr
2015 hallo und herzlich willkommen bei
tadort Deutschland mein Name ist mkro
Kasimir und ich bin Stefan Netzeband ich
habe euch ja gerade an diesen 7 januar
2015 geführt als am Vormittag der ganzen
Welt klar wurde dass da etwas
Furchtbares im Gange war
[Musik]
i dr new fo
the
[Musik]
terror es ist der 7 januar 2015 gegen
11:30 Uhr in Paris als sich in der Rü
Nikola AP diese makabre Szene abspielt
zwei schwer beewwaffnete maskierte
Männer Strecken einen bereits verletzten
Polizisten nieder während Stefan also in
der Bildredaktion die ersten Bilder aus
Paris schneidet macht sich Bild
Chefreporter Frank Schneider auf den Weg
ja ich kann mich noch genau erinnern an
dem Tag ich war auf dem Rückweg von dem
Termin im sehr frühen in die Redaktion
und dann hörte ich das im Radio und auch
wirklich keine Z Minuten später
klingelte schon Malin Telefon und es war
jemand aus der Chefredaktion der dann
sagt du musst sofort nach Paris da ist
ein schlimmer Terroranschlag passiert
auf Kollegen auf Journalisten in der
Redaktion und die Täter sind auch noch
auf der Flucht haben auf der Flucht
offenbar auch schon Polizisten
erschossen und du musst da sofort hin
und da ich immer eine Tasche im Auto
habe für eine Woche falls mal irgendwas
größeres passiert und man sofort weiter
muss bin ich dann auch überhaupt nicht
erst nach Hause gefahren od in die
Redaktion sondern wirklich sofort
Richtung Paris ich kann mich no erinnern
wie es ins Navi eingab und dachte wie
lange brauchst den jetzt wohl waren dann
ich glaube ungefähr halb Stunden und ein
Fotograf ist mitgekommen Mark Luca der
auch Muttersprachler ist der in Paris
geboren ist was für mich natürlich ein
großer großer Gewinn war weil er sich in
Paris sehr gut auskennt wie gesagt
Französisch schließend spricht als
Muttersprachler ja und dann sind wir
dorthinefahren und er hat im Auto direkt
Internetradio gehört aus Paris und hat
mich dann immer informiert mehr oder
weniger im Minutentakt und es waren halt
einfach sehr dramatische Dinge die man
da erfuhr und die Täter eben auf der
Flucht was auch neu war bei so einem
Terroranschlag und ja und dann sind wir
diese 5halb Stunden dorthin gefahren und
das waren somit die aufreibendsten fünf
Fahrstunden die ich in meinem Leben
erlebt
habe Charlie do erscheint einmal in der
Woche neben le Canin gilt sie als die
bedeutendste Satire Zeitschrift
Frankreichs die Redakteure legen sich
nicht nur mit der französischen Politik
an und zwar heftig sondern schuen sich
auch nicht den orthodoxen Islam aufs
Korn zu nehmen so hatte Charlie ebdo im
Jahr 2006 Mohammed Karikaturen aus der
dänischen jülllandsposten nach
nachgedruckt unter dem Titel shariado
veröffentlichte die Redaktion im Winter
des Jahres 2011 ein Sonderheft zum
Wahlerfolg der Islamisten in Tunesien am
selben Tag wurde ein Brandanschlag auf
die Redaktionsräume verübt und am 7
januar 2015 also dem Tag von dem diese
Episode handelt erscheint erneut eine
Karikatur über den Islam mit der
Überschrift noch keine Attentate in
Frankreich und der gezeichneten Antwort
eines bewaffneten Islamisten warten Sie
ab man hat bis Ende Januar Zeit seine
festtagsgrüße
auszurichten an diesem 7 januar 2015
trifft sich die Redaktion morgens um 10
Uhr wie jeden Mittwoch zur wöchentlichen
Sitzung im Büro in der Rühe Nicola aper
im Zentrum von Paris um 11:30 Uhr
dringen die Brüder said und Sherif Kashi
maskiert und schwer bewaffnet mit
Kalaschnikows zunächst in das falsche
Gebäude mit der Hausnummer 6 ein indem
sich nur das Archiv befindet nachdem die
beiden Attentäter ihren Irrtum bemerkt
haben stürmen sie das Redaktionsgebäude
mit der Hausnummer 10 hier erschießen
sie insgesamt 11 Menschen Redakteure
Zeichner einen Techniker sowie einen
Polizisten der das Gebäude schützte die
Ermittler finden später 31 patronenhösen
vom Kaliber 762 in dem Haus der ganze
Überfall hat nur etwa 5 Minuten gedauert
die zwe Männer schaffen es nach einer
Schießerei mit der Polizei tatsächlich
zu fliehen ihr Auto wird gegen:30 am
Nachmittag in der Rum gefunden daran
liegt der Personalausweis eines der
Männer die sind also leicht zu
identifizen Sherif Kashi ist2 Jahre alt
sein Bruder 34 beide sind in
parisborener algerischer elternerif ein
dihadist der bereits im Jahr 2008 schon
mal verurteilt wurde die Behörden rufen
jetzt einen anschlagsalarm aus in
Straßburg R und charville mesier werden
Häuser durchsucht die Jagd geht los die
Gendarmerie wird mobilisiert die Polizei
und die Armee gut 88 000 Beamte
beteiligen sich jetzt daran im Laufe des
Tages erreichen auch Bildreporter Frank
Schneider und Fotograf Mark l die
französische Hauptstadt ja wir waren
dann auch an der Redaktion natürlich und
die verandung lief ja nach den Tätern
und durch die Kontakte auch des
Fotografen zu französischen Kollegen
wussten wir eben dass massiv nach ihnen
gefahndet wird und wir waren dann auch
noch bei zwei ratzien dabei in so
Vororten von Paris in diesen sogenannten
bonlius und da haben wir schon gemerkt
wie polizeifeindlich die Stimmung doort
doch ist das haben wir auch in den
letzten Monaten wieder gesehen was in
Paris und in Frankreich überhaupt los
war das haben wir auch damals schon
gemerkt sehr viel Einwanderer sehr viel
Nordafrikaner die da sehr sehr aggressiv
vorging auch gegen Journalisten und das
war schon ein sehr gefährliches Pfaster
eine sehr aufgeheizte Stimmung und wir
haben eigentlich bis tief in die Nacht
an der verandung mehr oder weniger
teilgenommen die fandung begleitet aber
die Täter waren erstmal mehr oder
weniger spol ist
verschwunden
Werbung das bringt der Tag für alle die
wissen wollen was heute wichtig ist bei
uns hören Sie die wichtigsten
Informationen des Morgens und die
Hintergründe dazu egal ob der
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine die
aktuellen Debatten im Bundestag oder
Krieg in Israel wir sind mit Reportern
und Korrespondenten vor Ort unseren
nachrichtenpcast gibt's immer montags
bis freitags ab 5 Uhr das bringt der Tag
ab sofort auf welt.de und überall da wo
es Podcast
[Musik]
gibt Werbung Ende versetzen wir uns noch
mal in die Zusammenhänge dieser Zeit
solange ist es ja alles nicht hier aber
manches vergisst man ja auch im Herbst
2001 hatten die Anschläge von New York
und Washington die Welt erschüttert zu
allem entschlossen Islamisten zerstörten
bekanntlich das World Trade Center und
Teile des Pentagon die ganze Welt sprach
bald danach von der Terrororganisation
al-Qaida 2004 starben bei
Bombenanschlägen auf Züge in Madrid fast
200 Menschen di Wochen später am 3 April
24 da sprengte sich der redelsführer
dieser Anschläge serhane Ben abdelmadjid
bei einer Razia in einem Vorort von
Madrid selber in die Luft dabei starben
sechs seiner Komplizen und ein Polizist
15 Polizisten wurden verletzt im Juli
2005 kam es in London zu insgesamt vier
Explosionen ausgelöst durch
rucksackbomber getroffen wurden dadurch
drei U-Bahnzüge und ein Doppeldeckerbus
dabei wurden 52 Menschen und die vier
Selbstmordattentäter getötet und über
700 Personen verletzt was würde nun nach
diesem schrecklichen 7 januar 2015 in
Paris Passieren der Anschlag auf Charlie
DAU war vorbei das Gebäude war gesichert
aber wo steckten die Täter was heckten
sie noch aus war das nicht ein mulmiges
Gefühl Frank Schneider absolut wir waren
morgens gerade aufgestanden mehr oder
weniger sehr früh schnell ein Kaffee
getrunken und dann waren wir auch schon
im Auto und dann kam sofort die
Nachricht es sei auf eine Polizistin
geschossen worden in monouge das ist im
Süden von Paris und wir sind dann dort
sofort hingefahren und hörten dann schon
angeblich auch mit einer Kalaschnikow
und es ging da wohl um eine Aufnahme
eines Verkehrsunfalls ja dann ist auf
diese Frau geschossen worden aus einem
Auto heraus und die Polizei stellte sehr
schnell eine Verbindung her zu dem
Anschlag auf Charlie abdau und dann
wurde auch der Bereich dort abgeriegelt
dann hieß es der Täter sei
möglicherweise hätte den Wagen stehen
lassen sei geflüchtet zu Fuß dann wurden
dort ganze Stadtviertel abgeriegelt dann
kamen die Spezialeinheiten die
Antiterror kommmandos der Polizei mit
Panzerfahrzeugen und dann wurde alles
durchsucht aber gefunden wurde auch dort
nichts aber die Spannung stieg natürlich
weil es ging jetzt am nächsten Tag
weiter jetzt wurde eine Polizistin
einfach erschossen und auf einen
Straßenreiniger wurde auch noch
geschossen der hat aber zum Glück
überlebt und die Situation war sehr
unübersichtig und auch irgendwie gefühlt
sehr bedrohlich weil wir das Gefühl
hatten die Polizei hat die Lage nicht
wirklich im Griff wer läuft da draußen
rum denn das war auch ungewöhnlich die
Beschreibung des Täters der auf die
Polizistin geschossen hatte war eine
komplett andere als die anentäter von
charliedau die Nachrichtensender bleiben
jetzt mit ihrer Berichterstattung
permanent in Paris knapp 10 Jahre nach
dem Horror von London bewegen sich
wieder Islamisten mordend durch eine
europäische Hauptstadt niemand weiß wann
es aufhört niemand kann vorher sagen ob
und wo es die nächsten Toten gibt wie
sich zeigt stehen dem Land noch weitere
Schießereien und eine geiselname bevor
ja bevor die geiselam im jüdischen
Supermarkt war muss man sagen war
erstmal die Jagd auf die beiden
Attentäter von Charlie edau im Nord von
Paris und zwar dort im im ländlichen
Bereich etwas hügelig da gibt so kleine
Dörfer ganz ganz schön idyllisch gelegen
und da hatten wir dann am Abend des 8
Januar Hinweise dass dort die Täter sein
sollten Sie hatten nämlich Spuren
dorthin und die Polizei hat dann große
Bereiche dort ja durchsucht und hat sie
aber nicht dort finden können es waren
große Truppen von den spezialeinhitten
unterwegs wir haben die fast die ganze
Nacht begleitet es war eine sehr sehr
gespenstische Situation weil man dachte
sie haben sich dort im ländlichen
Bereich irgendwo in einem vielleicht
leerstehenden Haus versteckt aber
gefunden wurden sie nicht aber ich habe
noch einen Satz im Ohr bis heute der
Leiter der Spezialeinheiten sagte uns
dann an dem frühen Morgen das war so
gegen 3 Uhr als man die Durchsuchung
dieser Dörfer dann einstellte es ist
noch nicht vorbei die hören nicht
auf jetzt halten die Terroristen
Frankreich schon bald 48 Stunden langen
Atem für die Bildreporter beginnt Tag 3
dieses
terrordramas am nächsten Morgen gab es
die Nachricht dass gegen 8 Uhr die
beiden Täter erneut ein Auto gekarpert
hätten da im Norden von Paris und würden
jetzt wieder Richtung Paris fahren und
wir sind natürlich sofort auch in die
Richtung los und dann kam eine gute
Stunde später die Nachricht die hätten
sich verschanzt also Polizisten hätten
sie aufgespürt die sein jetzt geflüchtet
in eine Druckerei und hätten sich dort
in der Druckerei verschanzt und dann
sind wir auch dorthinefahren da WD alles
war natürlich alles abgeriegelt schwer
beewwaffnete Spezialeinheiten wieder vor
Ort man hört dann auch schon mehrere
Schusswechsel und während wir dann dort
in einem Garten von Anwohnern standen
ungefähr 300 m entfernt kam auf einmal
der Anruf jetzt hat's in Paris in der
Stadt eine Geiselnahme gegeben auf einen
Supermarkt das war gegen Mittag und dann
sind wir sofort wieder ins Auto weil die
Situation an der Druckerei war statisch
wir hatten auch noch Kollegen vor Ort
paul ronzimer war damals auch noch da
dann sind wir wieder nach Paris gefahren
und das war eine unglaublich
gespenstische Autofahrt denn die Polizei
hatte mehr oder weniger alle 1000 m an
der Autobahn einen Wagen querstehen dort
lagen Scharfschützen auf den Dächern
weil man überhaupt nicht mehr wusste was
ist hier überhaupt los jetzt sind da
diese Geiselnehmer Druckerei in Paris in
der Stadt Geiselnahme im Supermarkt man
hatte das Gefühl die Situation läuft
komplett außer Kontrolle und wollte
weitere Anschläge weitere geiselnahen
verhindern ja und dann sind wir durch
die ganzen Straßensperren dann bis nach
Paris gekommen und da lief die
Geiselnahme immer noch das war in einem
jüdischen Supermarkt und schnell war
eben klar das hat eine Verbindung zu
Charlie abdau und es handelt sich
vermutlich um den Täter der auch die
Polizistin erschossen hat wenn Frank von
Verbindungen in diesem Fall spricht dann
ist das nicht ganz unkompliziert nach
den wenigsten Terrorattacken dieser Art
gab es ja Verdächtige die man Verhören
konnte in der Regel kam alle ums Leben
außerdem übernahmen mit untergleich
mehrere Terrorgruppen die Verantwortung
für das Morden mit der Attacke gegen
chare BDO durch die Brüder kuachi
brüstete sich schließlich eine
Organisation namens al-Qaida im Jemen
offenbar unabhängig von dieser
vorbereiteten Tat war an Tag 2 aber ein
weiterer Akteur auf den Plan getreten
Amed
koulibali wie so viele islamistische
Mörder vor und nach ihm war koulibali
ein deep Junky Dealer und Schläger also
kurz gesagt eigentlich ein Loser er
kannte die Brüder kachi zwar aber dass
er am ersten Tag nach Charlie abdau eine
Polizistin erschoss und jetzt auch bei
der geiselnah in Paris mitmischte das
war laut alkeider nicht Teil des Plans
koulibali selbst behauptete allerdings
noch während der gesch im supermkt dass
er sich mit den Brüdern abgesprochen
habe also noch mal im Detail am 9 januar
2015 überfällt koulibali gegen 13 Uhr an
der Porte vincen im Osten von Paris
einen jüdischen Supermarkt und nimmt
mehrere Geiseln erfdert freien Abzug für
die K Brüder und droht bei einem
Polizeieinsatz mit der Tötung der
Geiseln einige von diesen Geiseln
schaffen es aber sich mit ihren Handys
bei Verwandten und der Zeit zu melden so
bekommen die Ermittler tatsächlich
Hinweise die bei einer Erstürmung
hilfreich sein könnten der Sender RTL
konnte nach einem Anrufversuch mithören
wie koulibali mit einigen Geiseln
diskutierte und seine Taten als
Vergeltung für die Intervention in Mali
und den Kampf gegen den is im syrischen
Bürgerkrieg
rechtfertigte wenn man die Muslime im
Ausland nicht angegriffen hätte wäre er
ein in Frankreich geborener jetzt nicht
hier es ist schwer an diesem dritten Tag
des Schreckens den Überblick zu behalten
denn während die geiselnah im Supermarkt
das Schlimmste für zahlreiche Kunden
befürchten lässt da ging ja auch die
Lage in der Druckerei unweit des
Flughafens Schal de go weiter ja also in
der Druckerei die Geiselnehmer die haben
dann eine Geisel sogar noch freigelassen
und sind dann am Ende mehr oder weniger
in ja Suizidabsicht kann man fast sagen
rausgerannt und haben dann aus ihren
automatischen Waffen geschossen auf die
Polizisten die draußen waren und die
waren natürlich in Deckung und haben die
Schüsse erwidert und die beiden haben
sich dann ja mehr oder weniger
selbstgichtet indem sie einfach
rausgelaufen sind in den Kugelhagel und
waren dann auch tot als das dann bekannt
wurde war ich ja in Paris an dem
jüdischen Supermarkt und da war die
große Sorge wenn das jetzt da passiert
ist an der Druckerei wenn die Kontakt
hatten möglicherweise dann eskaliert das
jetzt auch an dem Supermarkt und dort
waren ja noch viele Geiseln drin und da
hat die Polizei sich dann gegen 17 Uhr
entschlossen diesen Supermarkt zu
stürmen und und wir hatten das schon
gesehen aus unserer Distanz zwar konnten
wir trotzdem ein Einblick haben wie dann
Panzerfahrzeuge sich näherten von beiden
Seiten große Spezialeinheiten Truppen
also bestimmt 50 Mann von jeder Seite ja
und dann gab es plötzlich eine laute
Explosion einen wahnsinnig langen
Schusswechsel ich so noch nie erlebt und
dann war danach aber auch kurz danach
Ruhe und dann sah man wie viele Geiseln
weggebracht wurde zum Glück unverletzt
jedenfalls körperlich natürlich unter
psychischer Belastung ja und dann kam
hinterher raus dass der koulibali so
hieß der andere Attentäter vom
Supermarkt bei dem Zugriff dann auch
getötet wurde er ist dann mehr oder
weniger als die Spezialeinheiten rein
wollten rausgerannt auch in den
Kugelhagel und wurde dann getötet er war
bewaffnet mit der kalaschnikop und eine
Maschinenpistole hatte auch noch zwei
Pistolen dabei und was das gute war dass
die Polizei gestürmt er hatte auch noch
15 sprengstoffstangen und vier
zünvorrichtung dabei mit denen er ofmal
den ganzen Supermarkt die Luft sprengen
wollte das ist ihn zum Glück nicht
gelungen und deswegen konnten mehrere
Geisel noch gerettet werden trotzdem
sind vier jüdische Franzosen damals
gestorben die sind aber schon getötet
worden vor dem Sturm der Polizei durch
den Attentäter und ja und dann war es im
Endeffekt vorbei aber irgendwie hatte
man das Gefühl es ist noch nicht vorbei
weil genau wie du es geschildert hast es
passiert ja gefühlt jede Stunde etwas
und an dem Abend war es dann aber zum
Glück erstmal vorbei wie sich später
herausstellt hat kulibali schon am Abend
des ersten terrortages gewütet und zwar
an seinem Wohnort fonna im Südwesten von
Paris dort schoss er am 7 Januar auf
einen Jogger und ließ ihn schwer
verletzt liegen am Ende des dritten
Tages waren 17 Menschen Opfer des
Terrors geworden drei Haupttäter waren
ebenfalls tot immerhin konnten nach und
nach Helfer der kachi Brüder ermittelt
und verhaftet werden im Dezember 2020
verurteilte ein Pariser Gericht mehrere
Angeklagte wegen Beihilfe zu hohen
Haftstrafen der Hauptbeschuldigte Ali
risapol wurde der Beihilfe zu Verbrechen
mit terrorhintergrund für schuldig
befunden und zu einer Haftstrafe von 30
Jahren verurteilt für Frankreich für die
Welt und für Journalisten wie Frank
Schneider hatte der Terror eine weitere
schreckliche Eskalation erreicht das
ungewöhnlichste war diese schnelle
Abfolge verschiedener Attentate und eben
dass die ersten beiden Täter sich auf
al-Qaida berufen haben die wir ja alle
seit dem 11 September kannten der
islamische Staat war damals noch nicht
so bekannt und der zweite anentäter der
sich praktisch auf diese Attentate zwar
berief aber gleichzeitig sagte ich
mach's für den islamischen Staat das
heißt wir hatten plötzlich eine zweite
Terrororganisation und man schloss sich
zusammen und schlug halt parallel los an
verschiedenen Stellen mit verschiedenen
Zielen das war eine neue Qualität und
wir müssen ja auch sagen wir standen
damals am Beginn dieser ganz
schrecklichen Anschläge die Europa
erschüttert haben dann über mehr oder
weniger 2 D Jahre wenn wir an die ganzen
Attentate denken und das war schon eine
neue Qualität ich kann mich nur damals
erinnern es war bei den
Menschen in Paris so eine eine
trotzstimmung jetzt erst recht wir
lassen uns nicht einschüchtern das hat
mich sehr beeindruckt und das war
deshalb auch so interessant weil ich ja
dann leider nur 11 Monate später wieder
in Paris war und da war die Stimmung
muss man sagen eine ganz
andere und damit weiß Frank Schneider
schon auf die nächste Episode hin auf
die Anschläge vom 13 november
2015 wieder in Paris bis zur nächsten
Ausgabe euer Stefan und euer
Mirko dir hat diese Folge von tout
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Reusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei Tat
Deutschland